[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur le plateau
de la grande interview merci de nous
être fidèles ainsi une grande interview
enregistrée dans des conditions de
direct mais dans le respect scrupuleux
des normes sanitaires
puisque notre invité est installé dans
un autre studio de paris à l'abri des
risques liés aux qu'ovide 19 et juste ma
on va en parler de ce virus qui est en
train de bouleverser la planète
maintenant depuis le début de l'année
avec nous rodolphe gombergh bonjour
rodolphe gombergh vous êtes médecin
radiologue
vous avez été professeur des facultés
mais votre métier de radiologues ou de
photographes du corps humain comme vous
dites qui dit magie d'imaginaire vous a
ouvert les portes de la passion
artistique expliquez nous ce que vous
faites est bon en fait je dis souvent en
m'amusant que je suis imageur à plein
temps et e-magiciens temple c'est à dire
qu'en fait je suis à l'intersection du
chemin qui n'aurait pas dû forcément se
croiser mais qui ont pu permettre de
faire avancer d'un côté l'arrêt d'un
côté la science mais vous êtes médecin
ou vous êtes artiste
objectivement je suis les deux dans mon
coeur
j'adore sauver les gens et en
particulier c'est la prévention qui m'a
toujours attiré dans ce métier et le
diagnostic précoce et puis d'autre part
je me suis aperçu au mans spi rondeau
léonard que c'était l'art qui faisait
avancer la science et la science qui
faisait avancer la wii alors vous n'avez
pas de comparaison modeste a parce que
léonard de vinci est présent dans votre
vie en période de gel su bien loin de
lui et s'il avait pu bénéficier de ces
techniques invraisemblable qu'on a
aujourd'hui
il aurait été beaucoup plus loin que moi
turban il aurait fait autre chose que la
joconde dit - il l'a fait déjà l'homme
de vitruve et l'homme de vitruve c'est
la pureté anatomiques
oui alors vous avez découvert parce que
on en vient au fait que l'imagerie
médicale
c'est le coeur de votre métier avait une
dimension artistique esthétique capable
de provoquer une émotion
d'ailleurs le grand public le sait il
vous a vu à pompidou
il vous a vu dans les grands journaux
quasiment du monde entier quand vous
avez découvert le corps vide par par la
photographie mais ça on va en parler
dans un instant
l'image est belle mais mais en général
le mal qu'elle révèle il est terrifiant
la plupart du temps c'est vrai que c'est
souvent la plus belle image
contrairement à ce que pensaient les
anciens qui montre le plus de choses
moi mon grand-père radiologue avait des
radios en noir et blanc est signée à la
plume d'oie
mais aujourd'hui avec le virtual life a
que j'ai mis au point et la sixième
dimension
on a à peu près 12 milliards de
possibilités par image donc tout mon
travail depuis dix sept ans a été pour
chaque type d'organes et de pathologie
et puis dans l'art d'utiliser ces 12
milliards de possibilités mais je peux
dire vous avez vous avez donc inventé
cette et quand ça dans les années 90 la
3d pour la radiologie en gros c'est ça
j'ai utilisé des techniques que j'avais
trouvé aux états unis pour que ça l'art
et la science sur quelque sorte
ce mélange est alors on est passé
d'abord en scanner parce que tout ça est
passé par les scanners et aujourd'hui
par des scanners parce qu'on appelle low
dose c'est à dire qui n'ait n'irradie
pas quasiment et on était d'abord en
trois dimensions vous savez comme un
carpaccio des choses et on recréait le
volume ça s'appelle la 3d et puis après
on est passé à l' la quatrième dimension
au stade h kahnien de la leyre qu'en
plus du volume on avait la dynamique
puis la cinquième dimension le voyage à
l'intérieur du corps ou des objets et
puis maintenant avec les les hologrammes
la sixième dimension qui permettent de
voir et pour les changer à l'avenir est
déjà en a aujourd'hui le corps ou les
objets
venant vers nous sortons carrément de
l'écran très éprouvant proposer un
voyage fantastique à l'intérieur du
corps humain ou du cerveau est
d'ailleurs tout est parti du corps
humain exactement les 35 ans après la
réalité a dépassé la fiction du film le
fly cher le voyage faisait alors la
reconnaissance de la communauté
scientifique vous l'avez eue depuis très
longtemps
lalala l'affection et la reconnaissance
du grand public je crois que c'est venu
des femmes enceintes que à qui vous avez
offert la vision de leur bébé en trois
dimensions j'avais un ami qui s'appelait
jean michel arnold qui était président
du cnrs et qui voit un jour mais les
bébés en 3d que j'avais inventé et et
qui me dit mais tu devrait exposer sa et
moi en rigolant mais en rigolant je dis
ben ouais c'est pour pidoux orient et il
appelle aillagon qui dirigerait pompidou
à depok utilise je prends c'était une
belle face au mco bros alors
effectivement vous avez démarré à à
pompidou en montrant ses seins montrant
ces photos vous allez revenir d'ailleurs
à pompidou un prochainement mais vous
êtes aussi aller à à berlin séoul tokyo
new york
l'ex1 pétersbourg finalement que vous
n'avez pas fait alors que c'est votre
ville de coeur et oui je vais très vexé
parce que je suis d'abord très fier
d'être aujourd'hui dans cette maison de
saint pétersbourg dont viennent nous mes
ancêtres avant qu'il vienne en france
alors c'est très émotif et en plus je
suis sur les toits merveilleusement
installé comme à l'hôtel europa où on
voit les nuits blanches les fabuleux les
médecins vos confrères médecins ont très
vite compris l'utilité qu'il pouvait
avoir dans l'exercice de leur métier
notamment dans le diagnostic de vos
photographies
oui parce que s'ils voulaient d'abord
comme je vous ai dit tout à l'heure j'ai
initié le black virtual life art grâce à
des scanners haute définition grapel a
des super calculateurs
alors ça permet d'atteindre au maximum
ce qu'on appelle quelque chose
d'extraordinaire c'est la transparence
et à la fois transparent mais on voit à
travers
complètement à travers le corps alors
soit ça peut être pour des
représentations artistiques comme je le
fais à artparis et avec opera gallery où
on va le faire avec des roses mais ça
peut être le cerveau et c'est absolument
fabuleux de voir le cône de la mémoire
de papeete ou de voir le lait quand au
cal le coeur le coeur bat n'en 4 bis le
corps entier on a ici que vous étiez en
mesure de déceler la moindre début du
commencement d'une petite tumeur
ah ben c'est le but de ça c'est il faut
dépister plus tôt des lésions plus petit
et de façon moins agressive et c'est ça
qui m'a fait rester dans ce fantastique
métier parce que je me suis rendu compte
de ce que ça pouvait apporter alors
c'est l'outil rêvé de la prévention pour
vous oui c'est la prévention du futur en
fait c'est le futur déjà présents ce
jour là ouais mais mais mais certains
mais c'est si c'est un outil de
prévention qui doit aujourd'hui vous
vous amener à tirer tous les
hypocondriaques de dpi coins du monde
entier quoi parce que on a tous envie de
se passer au scanner il faut le faire à
bon escient dans tous les cas c'est aux
médecins et aux radiologues de se rendre
compte quand c'est nécessaire et quand
on va vraiment sauver les gens des
pistons plus tôt la demande est forte là
pour ça pour ce genre de diagnostic ou
pas ah bah ça a été par exemple l'eau au
moment du coup vite quand j'ai attrapé
moi même la maladie je tombais dans un
petit comme aller très léger et puis
tout d'un coup je me suis dit mais
pourquoi j'utilise pas ma technique de
3d de virton life a pour mentor axe
propres et pour le virus et c'est comme
ça que tout d'un coup j'ai pu montrer le
mal que l'on a dit dans match partout
d'ailleurs le virus comment et
finalement on a pu comprendre grâce à
des choses extraordinaires je suis
content que vous ne leur à pied parce
qu'en faisant en plus des tests
et quand c'était nécessaire et scanner à
l'eau doses injectées et grâce à ça on
pouvait en plus de la biologie des
pistes et des embolies pulmonaires et ça
devient encore plus important
aujourd'hui puisque tout le monde voit
l'importance des traitements
anticoagulants dans les formes
importante mais ce que je veux dire
mais on a pu grâce à ça et même sur
moi-même dépister une embolie pulmonaire
et on sait aujourd'hui que ce qui tue
vraiment dans le coup vite c'est
lamboley
alors c'est donc arrivé comme ça on sait
fortuit c'est à dire vous êtes tombé
malade et vous vous ai dit je vais me
photographier moi-même pour voir ce que
j'ai bah oui pourquoi pas c'était le
mieux placé pour le faire
et après le montrant à tout le monde que
le monde le dit mais on n'avait jamais
vu le virus comme ça et alors j'ai pu
suivre son évolution comme henry ça
s'aggravait ou au contraire comment ça
s'évacue est ce que j'ai appelé la
diffusion et puis je vais bien
effectivement le point principal
en dehors de ce qu'on appelle les verres
dépolis qui est un terme d'un des
radiologues mais qui est pas
complètement symptomatique du du virus
mais qui est très important et surtout
le fameux voyage dans les vaisseaux et
là ça s'est vraiment fondamental parce
que ça se voit là et ça a donné
pour le grand public ces photos
absolument extraordinaire qu'on a vu
dans la presse magazine et qu'on voit
défiler à l'écran là dans notre décor et
qui sont quand on a découvert le coït on
sait qu on sait comment ils et comment
quelle couleur il est qu'on a découvert
le mal l'e mail du mal
alors est-ce que lorsqu'on découvre le
mal comme ça on est on est plus rassuré
ou plus inquiété est-ce que c'est
anxiogène ou pas ah non globalement
toute cette prévention et ce diagnostic
précoce tout ça rassure totalement il
rend un tel service dans l'art dans la
technique que les différents médecins
vont employer pour sauver les gens dans
ce prêt
très rassurant contre vous avez été
soignée vous à et comment avez vous été
soigné oui alors on va rentrer dans un
autre
oui on va pas rentrer dans des malades
mais j'ai le professeur à haute avait
inventé très intelligemment le litre au
max le pape a inventé mais utiliser le
chloroquine chacun emporte ce que l'on
veut et aujourd'hui dans les formes
vraiment importante
pas forcément en prévention souvenant
des cas de gens qui ont des déficits
personnel mais dans d'éclat maladie
commence à se développer en particulier
je suis les sujets un peu plus âgée à
terre de et bien là dans les cas
nécessaire on peut donner des articles à
gland évidemment de susan étroit
contrôle des digues
vous vous sentez des points communs avec
le professeur raout cette originalité
cette façon d'être transgressif échoué à
prévoir
je préfère le professeur de retour vers
le futur on se retrouve dans un quart de
seconde on va faire une petite pause
[Musique]
bien retour sur le plateau de la de la
grande interview avec le professeur
gombert rodolphe gombergh radiologue
mais aussi artistes là on l'a vu
beaucoup parce que il a inventé un
système de photographies en trois
dimensions de ces radiologie qui ont
totalement bouleversé la science la
façon de faire un diagnostic mais qui
ont aussi apporté une dimension
émotionnelle très forte et c'est ça vous
intéresse presque davantage que le côté
scientifique finalement l'émotion que
dégage les photos oui mais c'est vrai
que j'ai toujours considéré grâce ces 12
milliards d'image que j'ai mis dix sept
ans à classer pour chaque type d'organes
et chaque type de pathologie est à dire
on a inventé des courbes avec mes
assistants non seulement médecin mais
informaticien qui paie un thème pour
chaque type d'organes et chaque type de
boîte au logis d'avoir une course
spéciale ça c'est parfait comme ça et
mais aujourd'hui on peut facilement
jouer avec ses 12 milliards de courbes
mais mes collègues ne peuvent pas de
dire on n'a pas le temps puisque les
différents logiciels moi j'ai inventé le
virtual life à leval art que j'appelle
hervé g rand alpin de bombay mais tous
les grands fabricants aujourd'hui essaye
de faire ça aujourd'hui libre du général
eletric avant le premier d'ailleurs est
une boîte et ragaine qui s'appelait
helsinki avait inventé la double barrel
mais tous les grands fabricants de
matériel aujourd'hui ça que c'est ça le
couplage important de du scanner et de
l'informatique en fait oui hélas hélas
on alloue c'est le grenier le grand
progrès de 28,6 et l'outil d'avenir pour
pour formuler un diagnostic et la
prévention le scanner d'ailleurs et
l'irm
mais c'est surtout le mariage de
l'imagerie médicale et de l'informatique
des opérations qui aujourd'hui sont très
chers qu'ils ne peuvent pas être
généralisée mais est ce que vous pouvez
imaginer que ça le coût de revient le
prix de revient va baisser
ah non mais les prix ont déjà énormément
baissé
et on peut faire ça même en comme je
vous le disais en 3d maintenant presque
immédiatement des images que je mettais
il ya il ya encore deux ans trois heures
de calcul matin je les ai en quelques
secondes
c'est à dire qu'on peut quasiment
l'offrir à a vraiment beaucoup de gens
voilà alors votre vos inventions vos
recherches vous innovation vous ont
amené j'allais dire presque par hasard
dans le débat public aujourd'hui
concernant le le coc vide alors qu'elle
évoquera depuis ce que vous avez été
malade puisque vous avez été
photographiée on en a d'ailleurs vu des
photos et issa qui déroule là derrière
en décor du plateau quel est aujourd'hui
votre analyse de la façon dont nos
sociétés ont réagi à cette épidémie
malheureusement à quelques semaines près
on a vraiment perdu du temps et même sur
le traitement on a perdu aussi du temps
et moi heureusement il ya quatre mois
j'ai commencé avec des médecins
américains et italiens à dire c'est pas
le plus le mot nerfs qui est prédominant
mais le vasculaire ça et ça aboutit
aujourd'hui à des changements
stratégiques petit capot mais vous avez
le sentiment de ne pas avoir été écouté
un peu comme le professeur raout a le
sentiment de ne pas avoir été entendu
oui mais le professeur à ottawa a mis le
sujet sur la chloroquine et il n'y a pas
que cela
mais au déjà un virus qui au bout de six
mois à a permis tout ce qu'on permet
aujourd'hui rend traitement c'est quand
même déjà fabuleux que je sache ni le
sida n'a trouvé un vaccin ni beaucoup
d'épidémie ont mis beaucoup plus de
temps alors on peut accuser les médias
effectivement de d'avoir un peu trop
focalisé les débats mais en réalité on a
quand même été finalement assez vite
est ce que est ce que la peur du corps
audard n'a pas fait plus de dégâts que
le corona lui même
oui mais c'est une évidence a marre je
ne le serais ce que la grippe tue est
chaque année quinze mille personnes et
il y avait personne pour pour dire ça
dans les grandes alors comment
vous analysez aujourd'hui la situation
actuelle du virus
on assiste à un rebond on assiste à un
retour une deuxième vague ou simplement
une évolution quasi naturelle qui fait
qu'on va être obligé de vivre avec
pendant très longtemps
bale professeur raoul labyanit d'abord
leur la courbe d'un virus est
normalement classique ans disparaît dans
les grandes universités d'asile l'on dit
aussi bon il se trouve que comportement
et surtout le nécessitent économique et
malheureusement les idées comme faire
aujourd'hui les jeunes faire trop de
choses que génial bien sûr mais fait que
des plus vieux vont l'avoir
alors le problème c'est de faire que
même si on l'a eh bien ça soit pas trop
grave et c'est ce qui a l'air de se
passer
il ya encore des cas aujourd'hui mais
globalement c'est un peu mon grand papa
il faut surtout pas baisser les bras
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire rodin
combelles vous êtes masque ou pas
masquer masque tout le temps ou pas mme
ardon bien sûr qu'il faut être masqué il
faut être masqué et reste de la vie
civile le bien respecté c'est
fondamental sinon si on veut faire que
l'un l'économie marche et donc qu'on
soit obligé de 2,2 des fins de libérer
la vie il faut que par contre on est
quand même un comportement conscient
conscient responsable quand vous vous
parliez tout à l'heure vous paraissiez
tout à l'heure assez optimiste sur les
progrès de la science sur la
connaissance du duc o vite alors il ya
eu évidemment au début vous
photographier qui nous qui ont fait
avancer un la vision qu'on avait deux
noeuds mais depuis il ya eu un certain
nombre de
de découverte est ce que vous estimez
que le vaccin est possible à échéance
assez rapide
c'est très difficile à dire d'abord est
ce qu'on aura besoin du vaccin en
principe oui il ya un vaccin russe qui a
été endossée par l'université à
l'hôpital hadassah en israël on sait pas
quelle vitesse ça viendra ce qu'on sait
c'est qu'on a perdu effectivement du
temps sûrement à cause des chinois
qu'ils ont tellement obsédé par là les
chauves-souris qui n'ont pas de cancer
alors c'est ceci explique un petit peu
que que ça ait commencé comme ça avec
les marchés couverts et les marchés au
contraire découvert et les chauves
souris vous préciser ce que vous venez
de venir vous vous sous-entendez que les
chinois mangent des chauves souris parce
que les chauves souris n'ont pas de
cancer donc ça va ça va améliorer leur
propre situation c'est ça leur donne
quelque part le pouvoir de la
chauve-souris ça paraît à s'exprimer
l'écran virologues savent cela est ce
que l est est ce que le traitement en
lui même vous pensez que si on n'a pas
de vaccin entre pourra peut-être comme
le sida trouver un traitement
le très regardé le sida aujourd'hui on a
vu les morts qu'il y avait au début
1 on n'a toujours pas de vaccin mais
objectivement bon ça a mis beaucoup
beaucoup plus de temps que ce qu'on
arrive déjà à faire avec le co vie
d'aujourd'hui qui quand même dans pas
mal d'endroits commencent à disparaître
bon ça va mettre du temps parce qu'on
est obligés d'ouvrir entre guillemets et
c'est tout dépend des des comportements
des gens dans chaque pays dont dans
chaque région dans chaque école partout
vous trouvez que les français sont pas
raisonnables
vous vous trouvez que ce sont des
enfants inconscients ou
vous considérez que après tout non plus
comme tous les jours il n'y a pas de
généralités il ya des endroits où ça se
passe formidablement bien d'ailleurs les
chiffres qu'on voit des gouvernements
montrent les zones où ça se passe mieux
mais on peut toujours faire mieux mais
la réalité c'est qu'il fallait commencer
plus tôt et que là on a perdu à cause
d'eux des chinois peu de temps avec tous
les gens qui ont été obligés d'aller
dans les hôpitaux avec les pierres
oxygénation avec les accusations alors
qu'on aurait pu passer à des traitements
plus simples plus vite
oui c'est ça le l'erreur du départ ça a
été de ne pas mesurer la façon dont ça
pouvait évoluer quoi je reviens là pour
terminer à votre passion finalement qui
est maintenant d'utiliser l'imagerie
comme instrument artistique instruments
d'émotion on en revient à ce qu'on
disait au début entre l'art et la
science
quel est le moteur pour rihanna alors en
fait je me suis mis à utiliser par
exemple un être une pomme qui paraissait
comme un comme un coffre fort de
joailliers ou alors en passant dans les
roses comme je vais montrer à artparis
en 6 dès maintenant c'est à dire en
hologramme eh ben on voit le voyage à
travers les pétales les pistils cette
fois ci c'est le voyage fantastique mais
à travers des vies de toutes sortes et
le l'exposition stade c'est amusant va
s'appeler flower power alors en anglais
ça veut dire le sexe delà des fleurs est
en panne en état tout voir et en art
c'est particulièrement émouvant l'assise
des parce que on sent que c'est ce qui
va se passer dans l'avenir tant dans les
salles diop que dans les salles de
diagnostic médical que dans l'art oui
tout ça va ce oui c'est ça le votre
message finalement veille que c'est
c'est la même chose c'est la même chose
ouais
mais l'émotion l'esthétique prépare le
terrain à à l'opérationnel exactement
c'est il faut pas vouloir séparer
l'art et la science est une bêtise on
aurait dit ça à léonard pour revenir à
lui quand même le génie des génies il
aurait rigolé de toutes ses forces
malraux disait il nous restera l'art et
la religion et la croyance
comment vous situez la croyance alors
moi je la vois je tairai un petit peu
d'un d'un côté bouddhique
parce que j'ai eu après pompidou
j'ai eu la chance d'avoir un grand
directeur du musée guimet et la nuit en
secret au passé les bouddhas du musée
guimet au scanner et là on a trouvé des
trésors du 11e siècle un livre
fantastique avec les lettres au nord
donc en scanner on peut voir le livre
sans l'ouvrir c'est probablement une des
pièces les plus émouvantes que que j'ai
fait et alors j'ai envie de vous dire
que la réalité c'est comme un visage qui
se reflète sur la lame d'un couteau
c'est à dire si la façon dont nos taux
l'on regarde qui compte
ça c'est un thème très bouddhique ou
alors l'illusion et la première
apparence de la réalité c'est aussi ce
que disent les gros sel ou dick
mais tout ça c'est de la philosophie le
goût du pain c'est pas de la religion
ouais non non mais on est quand même
encore à la frontière entre l'art et la
science on en revient à à sa merci
beaucoup
rodolphe gombergh cette émission est
malheureusement terminée vous la
retrouver on vous retrouvera bientôt à
pompidou d'ailleurs vous retournez à
pompidou on retrouve les missions en
rediffusion sur la chaîne vous retrouvez
l'émission aussi sur les réseaux sociaux
et puis sur le site internet
rt france point tva très bientôt
[Musique]